what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with ultimate Invasion and I'm
really excited to see what you guys
think about the story because one it's
amazing and two the ending is nuts so
here's the thing this picks up in the
aftermath of the gigantic attack that we
saw at the end of the last video which
is to say all these different versions
of like Captain America and vision and
so on Thor whatever just appearing out
of nowhere and going against like the
maker and his forces now remember the
maker is a version of Reed Richards from
an alternate reality called The Ultimate
Universe that has long since been
destroyed what he's doing here is he's
manipulating the history of this
universe to turn it into the ultimate
universe that's why it's called 6160
instead of 1610 which is the normal
designation for the Ultimate Universe in
Marvel Comics but following that
gigantic attack we end up picking up in
latviria now you guys are going to
another probably ask the question where
is Doctor Doom we will find out but
here's the thing it initially takes
place with Anthony Stark meeting
Emmanuel DeCosta now much like Tony
Stark the way he inherited his money
from his father following the death of
Howard Stark Robert DeCosta had
inherited his money and his company from
his father as well the difference here
is that neither of the dads are dead
both of these guys are still very much
alive but the other thing about this is
that we learn a few things that are kind
of finicky right Howard Stark has never
really been in this room with these
people before and most everybody here
that he sees are straight up villains
right they're bad guys on the world
stage they're the enemy and they have
been for a pretty long amount of time a
really good example of this is Sunspot
who is like an X-Men right he's a good
guy he's a hero in the traditional
Ultimate Universe the kicker to this is
that in this reality not only is he a
villain but whenever he has the mask on
and he's operating as a hero you cannot
talk talk to him directly right if you
try to they'll have you put to death the
only thing you can do is talk to his
really the voice as they refer to it
known as Viper it just works that way
right that's just kind of how he runs
things he's extremely hardcore then you
have what's called raw and konshu which
are basically these two guys that kind
of rule the upper and lower kingdoms
which is to say raw only talks when it's
daytime konchu only talks when it's
night time so it's really interesting
how these guys all kind of function but
then we're introduced to a guy named
Henry duggery who possesses both the
sword of Might and the Amulet of right
now for those of you guys who don't know
what that means you've probably heard of
the superhero Captain Britain Brian
Braddock of course that was a great big
huge talking point during Avengers end
game when Peggy Carter had mentioned
Brian Braddock's name and everybody was
super excited and so on and so forth
Brian Braddock is a British superhero
who attained what was called The Amulet
of right which basically allows him to
turn into Captain Britain he's not crazy
astronomically powerful or anything but
in order to get the emulative right he
had to make a choice he had to choose
between that or the sword of Might very
rarely do you ever see a Captain Britain
that actually has both this guy does
which makes him immensely powerful but
then we're introduced to the legendary
Hulk and the legendary Hulk like we
mentioned in previous videos just stands
in stark contrast to the Ultimate
Universe Hulk that we're traditionally
familiar with the Ultimate Universe Hulk
was like a cannibal right he was crazy
he would just like consume human beings
there was a really cool story where he
ripped Wolverine in half I mean there's
all kinds of crazy things with his
character but this kind of almost
basically heroic version right the guy
who has really achieved Transcendence
and moved Beyond any measure of violence
and it's more almost like a monk than
anything else it's pretty wild for those
of you guys who are familiar with the
Age of Apocalypse storyline in the 1990s
he's very similar to the way Kane Marco
was back then the way that Juggernaut
was during that point in time and he's
very similar to The Hulk during House of
M if I remember correctly because I feel
like he became a monk in that story as
well but the cool thing here is that
when the legendary Hulk shows up Howard
Stark starts asking questions and he's
like look I mean every like what's going
on here like these guys are all bad guys
right like these guys are all villains
like what in the world is happening here
and so everybody kind of looks at him a
little bit funny like what do you mean
they're all villains right and that's
when it starts to Dawn on all of them
Howard Stark doesn't fully understand
what's going on here seemingly Obadiah
stain did but if he did he never made
Howard Stark aware of how the world
actually functions now this reveal that
I'm going to bring to you is one part
crazy right but also genius at the same
time and it's just straight up
diabolical right so the way this works
is that on Earth in this reality due to
the mechanations and the manipulations
of the maker everybody in this room is a
villain but no one's a Villain at the
same time right the response of the Hulk
is I promise you Mr Stark however it
might appear to the World At Large there
are no enemies in this room the response
of Howard is I think you're forgetting
the Eastern conflict and that event in
the Pacific what about the winter
apocalypse I could go on ask any man on
the street and they would disagree as
with history as would I and the response
of the legendary Hulk is that is the
world as you know it look around this
place and you will see that there are
seven major territories represented and
though we have not yet fully circled the
sun when our time has come each of our
Nations will play the quote-unquote
adversary just as the rasputans do now
while inside our non-adversarial Nations
we rally our citizens against this great
evil and all participate in whatever
pageantry is required then at the end of
a generation another territory one that
has spent the previous age becoming more
and more belligerent assumes the
quote-unquote Rogue State mantle while
the previous one engages in a generation
of performative regret it is amazing
like this just the sheer scale of this
the general human population has no idea
that this is happening they have no idea
it's going on right the territory of the
rasputans are bad guys why are they bad
guys because they do terrible and awful
things and so on and so forth right but
then like the world unites against them
and the rasputans are defeated and then
the rasputans kind of spend all this
time my God we made we did such terrible
things we did such awful things but then
suddenly the entire territory of the
Hulk becomes evil right and they've been
becoming evil for quite some time and
they in turn are the ones of the world
rallies against and while humanity is
jumping from one foot to the next these
guys are just maintaining control it's
all theater it's all a show and what's
so crazy about this is looking at the
world right now doesn't really seem
impossible so it's a really phenomenal
thing because when Howard Stark hears
this it blows his mind just the level of
diabolical just the level of
manipulation right this is like one of
the most diabolical things that this
guy's ever heard of the entirety of the
human population is being manipulated by
the people in this room but what
legendary Hulk does is he answers the
question of why they would even do that
in the first place and the response
comes both by way of Emmanuel De Costa
as well as legendary Hulk himself right
the response is the problem has been
studied the maker did several iterations
of experimental societies inside the
city he has shown us the results peace
achieved through coercion or enforced is
never successful for a long-term
strategy the truth is humanity is
incapable of accepting peace now the
Hulk follows up and says to be fair not
all of us agree with such Universal
assumptions Mr Stark I believe that some
people many even are capable of
achieving a state of inner calm that
presents as peace I have to believe it
I've devoted my life to it but most are
incapable of maintaining that state in
perpetuity they can't handle the quiet
they can't let their action be in action
they can't maintain serenity with all
the hysterical babbling that surrounds
them so literally the entire argument
here is that Humanity needs War right
now it may just simply be that in the
Here and Now humanity is pretty
primitive right for all the advancements
and technology and stuff like that our
brain is still kind of dumb right it
hasn't quite caught up with like
Humanity in its current form it still
functions from decades ago right the
whole idea of fight or flight right two
cavemen are walking along the road and
they both hear rustling in the bushes
the one who ran away lived longer than
the one who went to go investigate you
know what I mean it's that kind of a
thing right so with all of that in mind
and realizing that the nature of
humanity is to wage war it is to fight
if things stay Restless for too long
Humanity will self-destruct then
ultimately they had to create this whole
sense of theater in order to bring peace
to what is basically a world that's
incapable of doing it on its own so it's
really really genius right it's really
cool and if I were a guy who was running
the world this is exactly what I would
do right it's just this really genius
thing but then you ultimately have Hulk
who says I wish it wasn't true but then
the response of the maker who shows up
and says it is and it always has been
and he says of course focusing on
shortcomings of Mankind's nature makes
it easier for those in this room to
gloss over the other major reason we do
this the little people hate us we Giants
who rule the land it's not how it used
to be in the ages gone by back then it
wouldn't have mattered right the
powerful would have just rolled right
over the powerless if need be but what
he says is this is why it's necessary to
give them something else to focus on
which we have gotten very good at doing
so it's really really interesting right
like literally they're just
manufacturing conflict they're creating
reasons for Humanity to be upset because
Humanity needs to be upset so it's a
very very cynical perspective of human
nature but the maker being what he is
and basically creating the city which is
a giant Dome where time passes
differently and he can effectively
create entire crops of societies this is
what he's come to realize it's very
similar to The Matrix right like the
motivation behind the nature of the
Matrix so the question that Howard Stark
has is if all of this right this will
choreographed dance of yours is to keep
the people happy so that we can get on
with the important work of what Giants
do do you mind telling me what the real
work is now switch over to the city
itself again just this gigantic Dome
that was created by the maker that
allows time to pass differently right
the immortus machine is basically how
time is used within the city it's the
way in which Reed is able to manipulate
time he basically created a time travel
machine that's really all it is right
it's like a giant time machine but what
he does here is where Howard Stark is
asking these questions there aren't a
whole lot of answers given by Reed
himself or the maker if we want to call
him that so what he does here is he
brings them to what's basically his
assistant and he tells him this is the
guy that you're going to be working with
now Howard Stark's initial response is I
work alone right I don't work with
anybody else but when it comes to this
whole process the response to the maker
is nobody works alone here everybody
works in pairs this here is Reed
Richards from this universe some say
he's the smartest man in this universe
and I'm inclined to agree only for us to
find out this version of read is Dr Doom
but that's not the kicker right here's
the answer to the question you guys want
to know where Victor Von Doom was at or
really where Docker Doom was at it's not
really Victor Von Doom it's basically
read here now how it is this read became
Doctor Doom we don't fully know and I'm
really excited to find out hopefully we
do but this is where the ending gets
crazy because some of you guys called
this and the last video some of you guys
were just like I know exactly who it was
it's in all those enemies from out of
nowhere to attack Reed I'm sorry to
attack the maker and all those guys some
of you guys already called it right
here's the thing we jump to the far
future there's your first clue right
there right and you have this version of
Captain America that says 4 000 years of
careful genetic engineering was all for
nothing Despair and the end of all
things was before us but we did not
yield now we have 6 000 years of better
stock righteous blood and your armies
have been replaced how much longer must
we wait Master how much longer can we
wait and this person silences them and
says do you see how he hides in this
game we play I ageless and Immortal in
real time my adversary a creature of a
temporal Vault a Time Thief if there
ever was one and what do we say of all
Pretenders the response of his army
their time will come and he says tell me
of my Legions right he's told they are
infinite they are Immortal they are
ready to die his response this pleases
me it makes me eager I have heard your
cries I have heard you ask me Kang is it
time and so I tell you truly the time is
now here's the question that we have to
ask and this is the thing that I had to
ask myself when it came to this is this
Nathaniel Richards Kane the Conqueror or
is it the Ultimate Universe came the
Conqueror because they are not the same
and Ultimate Universe Kang was dope all
indications is that it is Nathaniel
Richards and if you understand why I'm
making that statement then you know
right if you don't well then just roll
with it but just looking at him it looks
like Nathaniel Richards but I'm excited
let me know down in the comments section
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end if you need to get
caught up on Ultimate Invasion make sure
to click this link to the playlist and I
will catch you all later peace